Well,
a subset of males are are biologically
hyper aggressive.
You can identify them at two years of
age and they are the kids.
If you put a bunch of two year olds
together,
there's a small subset.
They're almost all males,
about five percent of males who will
kick hit bite and steel.
Okay.
So that's their biological programming,
let's say.
But the vast majority of them are
socialized by the time they're four
years old.
So that's amazing.
Yeah,
sure.
Absolutely.
Absolutely it is.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And the thing about about boys like that
is that if you socialize them properly,
it's quite a bit of work because they're
very combative.
My son was like that.
And if you socialize them properly,
then they can become unbelievably
useful.
They're courageous,
they're forthright,
they're,
they're not going to back down from a
challenge.
There's all sorts of massive utility in
that and that's this proper interplay
between the biological circuitry and the
socialization.
But you know,
and,
and with James Demaurice memo,
you know,
he,
he was,
he's been accused of taking a biological
essential list route,
which is not true.
One of the things James said is,
look,
there's credible evidence that there are
biologically mediated differences
between men and women at the level of
temperament and interest that are
actually large and profound and I would
say the science on that is sufficiently
settled so that someone can come out and
say that scientifically credible.
Now that doesn't mean it's right because
the scientists could be wrong,
but what you can say is that what James
Damore said was scientifically
uninformed.
It was scientifically informed,
but he also said,
look,
let's make the assumption.
I'm paraphrasing slightly,
but let's make the assumption that we
want to,
as a society,
we want to extract maximum useful
economic value from talented people.
So one of the things we want to do is if
some of those people are women and some
of them are men,
we want to understand the actual
differences between women and men so
that we can set up the workplace so that
both women and men can contribute to the
maximum economically so that they can
benefit as individuals and everybody can
benefit socially.
So you can use the biological.
So I mean,
for example,
one of the things,
here's,
here's a biological problem,
on average women are more agreeable than
men and I think that's because agreeable
people are self sacrificing and I think
as a woman you need to be wired to be
self sacrificing or you won't be able to
tolerate taking care of infants.
That's my sense of it.
Okay.
Now there's some problems with that.
It's like,
let's say that a huge part of female
wiring is,
is tilted in the direction of the
necessity of self sacrifice for infant
care.
Okay.
That doesn't equip women very well for
dealing with aggressive meant because of
aggressive men and infants are not the
same creatures.
So women play a pay,
a price beat,
being optimized to some degree for
infant care.
They pay a price that they're less,
uh,
what would you call prepared?
That's one way of thinking about it.
Indeed with dealing with hyper
aggressive and competitive meant.
Well,
one of the consequences of that is that
agreeable people don't make as much
money.
And the reason for that is to make
You actually have to be disagreeable
because you have to go to your boss and
say,
give me some bloody money or something
you don't like will happen to you.
You have to leave.
You have to be able to fight
for an idea too.
But so there is something that,
this is a perfect test case.
So biologically speaking,
there's a very good reason for certain
kinds of wisdom to be biased in the
direction of manifesting in females,
females,
because they have the capacity to have
fewer offspring in a lifetime than
males,
uh,
are,
obligated,
as you say,
to,
um,
to care in a particular way.
And the fact that care and human beings
take so many years has resulted in
menopause emerging and menopause.
Essentially when a woman is done
producing new offspring,
her interests in,
uh,
her evolutionary interest,
which in this case I think our honorable
becomes synonymous with the lineage,
the population because her offspring
will either do well or do poorly based
on the population that they're in.
So women have a kind of farsightedness
about lineage.
And I don't think it has anything to do
with human women.
Actually,
this is a trait that we can see,
uh,
in females,
of other species,
so it's an ancient thing,
whereas males are high variance.
That is to say a male can have many
offspring in a lifetime.
Many males have no offspring in a
lifetime.
And that high variance means that to the
extent that there's wisdom that
surrounds risk taking,
that has traveled historically,
uh,
along the male path.
Now in modern times,
there's no reason that we can't look at
these two kinds of wisdom and
democratize them both,
right?
The fact is there's no reason if you're
born female,
that you can't tune into what has
historically been a male biased wisdom
and take advantage of that.
And we should be encouraging this.
There's no reason that people have to.
The problem is,
is that we can't actually have a
reasonable discussion about it because,
you know,
the discussion is often for stalled by
the claim that,
well,
men and women are exactly the same.
It's like,
it's,
that's not a helpful discussion.
And you know,
with the agreeableness issue,
I don't know exactly what should be done
about that.
But one of the consequences of it is is
that there's many reasons why,
why the pay,
there's pay differential between men and
women and the issue itself is very
complex,
but we do know that agreeable people
overall make less money in the same
positions and it's because they don't
negotiate on their own behalf very well.
Now it's conceivable that you could have
an intelligent public policy or
corporate policy discussion about what
to do about that.
Like maybe,
maybe the rule is something like you
review male salaries once a year and
female salaries every eight months or
something like that.
You know,
and I'm not saying that's a good idea.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying that if you,
if you take the facts on the ground into
account,
there are ways that you might be able to
use them so that you could,
and I'm not gonna say level the playing
field because I think that's an
appalling phrase,
but maximize the possibility of economic
across the genders,
which is obviously in everyone's best
interest.